- So the Bannon and Manafort pardons
might not actually shield those criminals.
Here's why.
Manafort convicted on
eight counts in Virginia
and two counts in D.C.,
but jury hung on 10 different counts
and a prosecutor rarely charges
all of the possible crimes they can.
It would confuse the jury,
but the thing is the Manafort pardon
only pardons the actual crimes
that he was convicted of.
So that means that a future prosecutor
might just simply charge
the crimes that they weren't
able to get a conviction
of in the first place
and the same goes for Bannon.
Steve Bannon's pardon only goes
towards offenses, actually charged
and there's a whole bunch of
other fraud related charges
that the government could have brought,
but hadn't at the time yet
and the same goes for Roger Stone,
George Papadopoulos, Alex van der Zwaan
and a whole bunch of the other fraudsters
that president Trump pardoned.
So if the Biden administration
has an appetite,
they can go after almost
all of these people
and get almost the same convictions
just on slightly different crimes
and heck a bunch of them
actually already pled guilty.
So it shouldn't even be that
complicated, but stay tuned
and as always, I'll see you in court.